hey everyone welcome back to the game
spud III demo stage here at e3 2017
joining myself and Cali plaguey is ash
Israel who is a game director of
Assassin's Creed origins welcome to our
stage great to be here yes and as you
said the press conference it's so nice
to finally say what your work in the
press conf
oh yes it's it's a pleasure to finally
be able to show it off it's been a long
road three and a half years working on a
game is a long time so we're excited to
finally be able to have to show it off
and have people play it so it's cool so
let's get me worked on it was Assassin's
Creed Black Flag
Black Flag so that was laughing yeah how
long was there did you at least get like
a vacation in between starting yeah
there was a little bit of vacation
little bit of downtime just to
re-energize everybody needs a bit of
that but pretty much right after Black
Flag we started SS acute origins we had
the concept of doing Egypt and ancient
Egypt so it was a thrill to be able to
bring this setting to life and so yeah
it's been a three and a half year road
to get to this point by the time we ship
it'll be four years which is a decent
amount of time to do a massive game yeah
what was the I mean obviously Egypt
always it always felt like the perfect
place for Assassin's Creed right but why
why did you why were you the one to
finally take it on I guess so when when
we started this project we had this this
urge to do something that was kind of a
reinvention of Assassin's Creed in terms
of gameplay narrative storytelling world
but at the same time somehow
authentically AC and so this you know
this brought us to talking about the
birth of the Brotherhood and how can we
tell a story that was really powerful
for the series and then how do you tell
that story in a context that can be epic
and bigger than life and so Egypt was a
natural fit for us it's been a dream for
all of us to do this
technologically was always hard because
the you know doing a giant country of
this scope making sure you making sure
it's seamless
you know whether you're underwater going
through a cavern going - a giant city
that we wanted this flow to be immersive
and seamless so we reached a point where
technologically we could achieve that
the will was there the intention was
there so we just went for it
um I do want to talk about because we're
looking at combat right now the comment
has been revamped yes quite a bit
very exciting me as well yeah so um I
just wanted to ask a little bit like
what exactly is the process there of
like switching from the traditional
Assassin's Creed style I mean there's
more flexibility with what you can do in
combat now yeah for sure so one of the
things we set out to do early on was we
you know by doing such a large landscape
we knew that bows mattered and we wanted
the the third-person shooting element to
be super strong and then we asked
ourselves well how is that going to mix
with melee combat so it had to be smooth
seamless if somebody wants to be kind of
a ranger playstyle but within the melee
combat system it should work for them
and so then to do that we pretty much
said okay let's reinvent fight the old
the old paradigm of fight was really
it's a what we call a paired animation
system so we press attack the hero and
the enemy come together they play an
animation now we've gone to a hitbox
based system which pretty much means you
swing your weapon if something's in the
way it gets hit if it's not well you
swung an open air and you can be hit so
all of a sudden the size of the weapon
the length the speed your position
compared to the other enemies all of
this matters so here as an example that
was swing that missed
luckily followed up well you notice here
enemies attack almost at the same time
we're all waiting no more waiting for
the counter but oh you have a lot of
combos a lot of different moves all the
different weapons have their own combo
set we wanted players to to experiment
with all the different weapons and to
find depth in the system and this links
to our RPG mechanic so we've gone much
deeper into the RPG realm
so all weapons have not only levels and
stats but also attributes and properties
so for example you know fighting with a
poison-tipped sphere is nothing like a
khopesh that does bleeding damage
khopesh is the classic Egyptian sword
here we have a boss fight so this new
fight system allows us to do things like
boss fights which is wonderful who have
been excited to do that so we have boss
fights in arenas like this but also in
quests and side quests guys that are
just roaming in the world that are
optional but for the people who
love the challenge of combat or stealth
there there they give us some rewards
we're thrilled that we have them I
played this boss sequence and I actually
was really surprised because I led him
into one of those spiked Kollek columns
you can see and it took so much day
right here yeah and this might be my
game plan I remember right now I'm gonna
judge you was actually pretty decent it
might be somebody else's like I might
had a yeah but I got him to like just
fall into it I thought I was really
interesting I liked being able to I mean
that that that falls into the realm of
player choice like I was able to kind of
manipulate his movement rather than
attacking brute force exactly we we
wanted that the environment also has an
effect if you choose to use it so in the
in the combo set of the of each weapon
you have abilities that can push enemies
put them on the ground it's kind of
stuff so we've seen a lot of people who
know how to use the the two-handed axe
to use its pushing capacity the combo
that pushes an enemy into those spikes
and they do a lot of damage yeah yeah we
wanted that the combat is super flexible
now we talked about combat a lot but
stealth is also somebody ran into that
spike was it your playstation I don't
think this is my neck now you're not
Salva with me oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
that did happen to me goodness but
there's a lot of comparisons when the
combat was kind of first being shown off
I don't miss comments was it like Dark
Souls you guys hesitant to use that cuz
I mean I know we are always hesitant to
say like oh yeah the combat psyche
though yeah I mean that was the first
person I thought of too it's like the
last one you want it's like the new you
know allowed to say visceral right like
the new visceral is the combat sector or
epic yes yeah we're definitely exactly
um know the combat you know we started
this combat system really at the
beginning of the project we wanted
something that was really fresh for
Assassin's Creed and for our fans as
well but something that was accessible
but not necessarily forced you can
actually go through the game if you want
to play like as a as a stealth assassin
you can go through the game that way or
as a ranger you know using the bow but
yes we I mean we we looked at a lot of
references we we asked ourselves what
is the combat system that makes sense
for Egypt for these types of weapons for
the character that we play which is his
name is byuk he's a Magi and this was an
actual ancient line of warriors I've
seen the mummy I know about the mummy is
one of our personal fave yes
well I think we've taken control of that
naming now so these these guys were you
know trained warriors and they trained
in many different styles of fight with
with many different types of weapons so
that's what we went for
I'm super thrilled with what we have
it's why we even have the demo playable
here it's we want people to see that we
pushed ourselves to achieve something
different that it's that it's deep and
powerful and there's a huge a huge curve
to its depth we're excited by it but
it's not just the combat that you guys
into like revamped it's also the I mean
the other big tentpole of Assassin's
Creed gameplay is parkour yes but I mean
it's different out so I mean I found
that with the more recent games it's
been oversimplified to a place where I
it's not as enjoyable right like in
syndicate you had that little grappling
gun which meant they didn't have to
climb anything I thinking well I mean
we're here to talk about yes good
origins and syndicate that buildings are
super tall so there was a sense to it no
in our case it was you know we knew we
were building a giant world with a lot
of wilderness so we put a lot of effort
to how do you traverse this world you'll
see that if you've played it we worked a
lot on the responsiveness of the hero
when climbing when running making sure
that players have full control over byuk
so we we drastically changed the way
underneath the hood how all navigation
works and then we went further into into
like you have mounted you have mounts
you have mounted combat we have
different ships different boats camels
you can't do Egypt without camel horse
chariots no we worked on pretty much
fundamentally everything we we wanted
this experience to be as cohesive we
listen to the fans we listen to feedback
of of the previous ACS it was important
for us we wanted to take pride in
achieving something really cool for the
fans and for anybody who wants to try a
scene and along those like changing or
kind of
the departure from the AC formula what
was the thinking behind the RPG elements
like why move towards the action RPG
genre for Assassin's Creed yeah so going
more action RPG that the main purpose
was you know we we saw that our players
there were really two major types of
players the stealth players and people
love to do just combat and they're both
valid play styles there and one is not
better than the other and what we felt
is by going more action RPG it allows us
to give players control to dedicate
themselves to those play styles or in
our cases even being a ranger using if
you want to go full third-person shooter
you can we have a lot of different types
of bows so by doing that it means
there's a progression system that
supports this there's abilities that
support that that means we have a lot
more depth so as you go through the game
finding rare weapons legendary weapons
they have new attributes that kind of
change the way you play so it just gave
us a ton more depth it also gave us a
way to give rewards you know Egypt is
huge there's a lot of places discover
hidden tombs lost temples even caves and
the world is majestic and beautiful and
we wanted that there was a true
narrative and gameplay value to the
things you can find there and the RPG
element helped us achieve that speaking
of Egypt obviously I mean everyone came
things like ancient Egypt oh it took
place in like you know 100 years ban but
really it was like hundreds of years of
houses thousands three thousand years
yeah so how did you choose the
particular time period so when we looked
into this you know we we asked ourselves
do we go to the time of the pyramid the
building of the pyramids the issue there
was there was nothing else around oh it
was kind of an empty world sure you can
see a pyramid building but there wasn't
much else the we wanted to go to ancient
Egypt and when we looked around we
landed on 49 BCE which is at the time of
Cleopatra's ascension because it gave us
an opportunity to show Egypt after
centuries of grandeur and human
accomplishment and and these massive
monuments so there's already a built in
history that players can discover as the
heroes discovering it and then on top of
that it was the fact that
this is the moment of the demise of the
ancient world no the line of Pharaohs is
about to end the gods are going to die
the Egyptian Way of life is going to
drastically change and our hero byuk
he's the embodiment of Egypt we wanted a
character that was how can you
physically represent ancient Egypt he's
that representation he has in him the
beliefs the rituals he works for the
people of Egypt he has compassion for
them but at the same time he's wary of
newcomers he's he holds on to the ghosts
of the past who and the idea is who does
this person have to be what does he have
to do knowing that his world is about to
end and a new world is coming and this
is what eventually leads to the birth of
the Brotherhood as we knew it from AC 1
so we're a thousand years before I see
one Wow okay I wasn't holy a thousand
whole years I do have to ask you
mentioned Cleopatra will we get to see
Cleopatra where I see whereas asin's
Creed we play with history
I mean it's during her time of ascension
to her throne so of course we do play
with major historical figures with with
major historical events they are
integrated into the narrative so we have
we've changed to a quest structure so
there's a lot of stories we want to tell
of Egypt and it's and you meet a ton of
characters that when we did our research
what we found was there were hundreds of
amazing little stories real things that
happened that we wanted to propose to
our players to experience that and so we
put them in our quests and so you meet
wild characters a lot of them are
referenced from real people who existed
and and then our spin on it is how is
this all linked to the birth of the
Brotherhood - by X story and so yes you
meet some really fantastic historic
figures what I love about Assassin's
Creed is how deep you guys go with that
research I mean that in syndicate you
had spring-heeled Jack which is like as
someone from who lives in London being
spring-heeled Jack in a game is quite it
meant something it meant something are
you hoping gonna have that same a same
sort of feeling of discovery for people
who love things about ancient Egypt yeah
for sure we
you know we got a lot of historians
Egyptologists that we embedded into the
team we wanted to do this this time
period this culture these people their
beliefs we wanted to do it justice you
know it's it's it's not just a setting
for us we we take pride in representing
things properly you know in a game form
and so so yes there's a lot of
references to actual historic stuff you
know that the hieroglyphs it's not just
art on a wall actually say stuff know
that giant mural behind me yesterday was
a conference there's a there's a meaning
there all right meets get my books out
yeah Suns got you super fans I amazed no
one's uh I have people time wondering
how long I I shouldn't have even made me
said it but I was wondering how long
it's gonna take for people to to
translate that oh man you heard it here
first guy tried to translate that
actually I think you we've heard of here
first that is fascinating so I what
other like little ancient Egypt not
Easter eggs but like I used to be such a
huge change in Egypt nerd kid you talked
about in the presentation that I saw
like mummification beautiful part of the
thing what other you know rituals or
ancient Egypt specific things can we
expect so we know our our ceremonies our
rituals we've done a lot of studies on
this kind of stuff and we wanted that
players in a natural way through the
stories and through the quest that we
have that they experience this stuff you
know we want to answer things like well
what's actually underneath the Great
Pyramid I mean we know the chambers that
people have discovered but there is more
everybody knows there's more so we have
our answer to that and we have a ton of
pyramids tombs temples even if you got
into the mountains here we can see that
this is a little outpost but if you see
in the distance there's mountains
there's there's stuff in there for you
okay go explore the world we want people
to be lost in the world to be in awe of
its its scope the things you can find in
it the discoveries byuk is a character
who was you know he grew up in C WA and
the idea is when he's kind of leaving
his home and going out to the rest of
Egypt he's exploring it as much as the
player is so it's a it's a natural fit
so yeah for sure there's a ton to
discover in the world
we had fun with it we had fun with it
what I'm also really interested about is
the mini-map is gone no longer my eyes
be kind of keep darting to the bottom
corner to make sure I'm kind of hitting
everything right what was it was it
liberating to sort of go to the mall
compass based system yes it was you know
when we say we wanted to reinvent
Assassin's Creed we really meant it on
every level from the macro to the micro
how does a player from the controller to
the feedback experience this game one of
the elements was yes we wanted to move
away it was it was a choice we made as a
design choice to move away from the
mini-map you know the world is stunning
it's absolutely beautiful I'm super
proud of our engineers and our artists
and we wanted people to look in the
world if you know you can see the player
has the ability to to flag the feedback
they want if you want to remove the the
quest feedback you can just flick it
flick it off if you you know send gives
you a lot of fever here we can see the
this enemy here we can see is level this
is by player choice if you want to see
this feedback you actively look for that
info no no we wanted people to be
consumed by the world to be immersed by
it for sure there's always the balance
of understanding what am i doing what do
I need to know about the current
situation I'm in and we challenged
ourselves on that and as I would say it
was actually very liberating from a
design sense to challenge ourselves on
this you know making games is we always
want to be challenged and pushing
ourselves and learning new techniques so
we pushed ourselves
obviously Eagles have a very long and
symbolic relationship with the
brotherhood and those senior like the og
eagle for sure than Brotherhood oh we go
far with sinew so a little tidbit you
want another yes do a little tidbit so
the view points so we thought about
viewpoints and we wanted to keep the
viewpoint concept because of the the
powerful legacy element of it but now
when you synchronize with a viewpoint so
you're actually training sending to be
able to Scout better so yes yes so if
you if you notice in every AC there's
always an eagle soar
around their points so we explained how
that came to be so we had fun with it
oh yeah Senna was she's she's that she's
the beginning of everything
Wow yeah are you Origen Arjun um what
else um it's also interesting that son
who seems to be like um a thing I like
about you soft is as a company you guys
seem to share a lot and in terms of not
only like gameplay mechanics but like it
seems like developers go out of the way
to help each other and share and it
looks like sending the way that she's
moving around and tagging people is that
happened in Far Cry primal you had like
the owl there was a known for crack who
came first so we had the Eagle as one of
our first prototypes three and a half
years ago the main actual reason for for
Zen knew was um it was actually linked
to Black Flag it was that when you go to
the you know what we called animus
travel with the with the ship with the
jackdaw the camera pans back and we
thought it was just such a beautiful way
to look at the world and it had a
peacefulness to it that that we asked
ourselves how can we look at this
beautiful open world from different
perspectives and someone said hey what
about it literal bird's-eye view so we
built a prototype of an eagle a very
simple you go at the time I'm sorry this
is an amazing way to look at our world
and so it was just it was a very easy
natural process for us to go to that
direction and and then we decided to
incorporate it into the tagging element
the scouting element stealth and so on
so it was it's a it was a natural step
for us to go to that direction with
Center was she also the inspiration for
Eagle flight are you not allowed to say
hey Eagle flight super cool game they're
doing their thing hard she just has to
ask I have to ask last about um Abstergo
the Animus yet alia what was that a
question
Wow or a statement so far that was a
statement I think uh well for now we're
we're really focused on ancient Egypt on
baek's journey and and you know the
mysteries of Egypt we just announced the
game so you know there's a campaign
there there's more information there's a
lot of stuff coming
you know for an hour focused on Egypt
and by it okay that's fine I like
suppose decent how acceptable yeah we'll
take it I do want to get back to the
exploration just a little bit because
one of the things I noticed when I was
playing is like NPCs including animals
have their own kind of they have their
own life they have their own cycle that
they go through and I got my boat got
sunk by a crocodile excellent yeah it's
funny member yeah and I had to research
to back that oh yeah I had oh yeah I had
to fight it underwater it was a whole
thing and then blood in the water
attracts more we went through an ordeal
I dare you I was like the end of my demo
is I just got wrecked by a crocodile but
um I wanted to ask about like building
that living breathing world as part of
my ex journey like how what is that like
what is yeah so so how it started was
when we when we decided to build such a
large world we knew we had to figure out
how do you populate this world properly
we needed some new technologies to do
that and so by by pushing ourselves to
to do that we said okay then let's give
every single NPC every single animal a
purpose a schedule you know farmers will
farm they'll go home and sleep they'll
eat they need to go to the washroom at
some point priests run rituals animals
sleep on they look for shade they have
homes to protect or the dairy their dens
and so we gave not only life and purpose
but also persistence and how that comes
into play and how does that matter to
the player it's that first in the quest
system by telling you hey you have a
target and you find some info that tells
you this target at night he sleeps in
his fort protected but he's sleeping in
a fort during the day he's out on his
chariot roaming the land and so at that
point it's for the player to decide do I
want to go fight him on his chariot do I
want to try to sneak in and stealth take
him out do I want to just fight his fort
and the idea is this happens with the
day/night cycle if you're you know 2
kilometres away and you decide to take
stand you out for a ride well you might
find him and might see he where he is in
the world and so that means he needs to
live in that world and he's to be doing
stuff if you catch I had a situation
once I kid you not
where I saw him fighting a bunch of
thieves a bunch of bandits they ended up
killing him he went in the wrong part of
the village and okay it was a sidequest
character so I had to go up to him there
he is he's dead I was kilometres away I
came up to him and he was dead and okay
so I had to pick up what I needed from
him and it was super cool you know was
he's really living in the world he's
doing something in the world and dying
in the world behind in the world so it
you know it gives us something unique
for our game and it really enhances the
quest structure and it was a needed step
to actually feel such a massive world
with with all this life so you could be
you could have a hit out on somebody and
you could find out find them dead
already by some unknown cause to you so
to some degree we didn't want that for
let's say some of the major characters
right sure we wanted the player to
experience those but we have a ton of
side quests where you have a lot of
different objectives not just targets
it's also people you need to meet by it
has a lot of informants that he needs to
go and get information from them and by
living in the world you know you can run
into a situation where something
happened or they went somewhere they
shouldn't have gone and we we fully
assume that it's even cool it creates
really unique experiences for our
players so we we've embraced it fully
embraced it we are running out of time
but tomorrow who you met yesterday yes
me to ask you what happened when you met
Miyamoto ah you moto yes that was
special that was a really special moment
so he was coming off backstage I was
going up next they had me up there like
Akash two minutes I saw him coming he
was getting his mic taken off I had
chills and the thing is I don't really
geek out I don't you know I've you know
celebrities are human beings
none of that gets to me miyamoto got to
me I mean this guy he inspired me he's
one of the greatest designers ever we
still use the design principles he
created you know in a sea in any third
person a third person game open-world or
not we use the designs they came up with
and so it was an honor so I ran I ran
down to him I like dude I'm gonna geek
out for a minute let me and he's like go
for it so so he's really sweet
with me we took some photos he was
having fun with me
gave me a little hug at the end of it Oh
Mike asked me you know
tell me a little bit about AC they told
me is like it looks beautiful he was
really sincere and sweet it was it made
my day
and then at that point like ash 10
seconds so it was there was a cool
moment it it only enhanced the day
enhanced being able to talk about the
game it was a super cool moment awesome
last thank you so much for joining us
really looking forward to playing screen
origins later this year for more from e3
2017 guys make sure you stay tuned to
games for calm